it was brought to my attention I worked
at the theater in Detroit I sold tickets
and was a protectionist and James
Baldwin came to the theater in 1980 and
he started talking about he said it's
exhausting
and I don't know if I can stand watching
it but I can't I couldn't take my eyes
off of it I thought I have to find this
movie and just sitting right there that
second row at the same reaction I
couldn't be that close to the screen I
had to go stand in the back to watch it
because he's such a towering presence
you know probably taught me two things
one the power of allowing someone to
present themselves before a camera and
also that Talking Heads aren't
necessarily a pejorative you know that
they can be that they can be used
artfully and cinematically I mean it
really is
I'm categorizable there are documentary
moments I think but then there are
moments that are just that just feel
real and it strikes me that it it's very
much of its time when it came out in the
in the late 60s it was it was all about
being real it was Cassavetes and method
acting and the beats and there was a
real there's this real premium on
authenticity and it felt like that's
also what it was about tonight I was
thinking of why did Bergman find this
the most fascinating film and I was
thinking of cries and whispers I'm the
death scene where she's crying out loud
and it's almost unbearable to watch and
some of portrait of Jason is so raw and
so emotional and so just real and
whether it is or not is just adding
another layer to it I work with Shirley
as her assistant editing it and and
stopped working with her before the film
was done and she made changes to the
film afterwards so when I saw the film I
actually didn't totally remember it and
the part that I remembered which is the
Shirley's monologue where she attacks
Jason wasn't in it and she must have
taken it out you guys what you saying I
just ask you about your your memory of
seeing it for the first time you you can
talk a bit more about that I was in my
early 20s and just coming out and it
freaked me out
you know I just it was a cautionary tale
and it was you know that's that's what I
don't want to it's end up as and that's
all I could see you know in my early 20s
really yeah I don't think I've ever seen
that kind of exercise a will on screen
before and one of the things I was
thinking about just watching again in
this screen and the big screen is just a
connection to black jazz hearing Miles
Davis mention and Karan McCray and
Willie Bobo I mean I feel like I guess I
never thought was being marginal I just
thought he sort of lived in the black
underground and which is an interesting
thing to see because I have friends and
just talking with me about this who seen
this movie and have a really hard time
watching it because the whole idea of
being a black man being victimized on
screen but I feel he's fighting back in
some way and again this is enormous
exercise of will I mean he's crying but
he's not crying and he's drinking and
he's doing drugs and he's basically the
last man standing at the party in a
weird way isn't he I mean the whole
thing also plays as a power struggle you
know who's gonna who's gonna control you
know what what the film becomes an
editing cut should not discover
discombobulated which was her word the
audience which means it shouldn't upset
you visually and throw you out of your
position or your your experience of
watching the film and I think that's why
she in the end used this technique with
out of focus some of which I think we're
camera problems but my favorite surely
moment was we were at the Amsterdam
Airport this was the early days of
airport security so there was a conveyor
belt for
an x-ray machine for carry-on baggage
and we were I can't remember we were
going but we were hanging out together
for a few days and she put her camera
bag on the conveyor belt and it was
about to go through the x-ray machine
and she realized that she had film in
the camera and she jumped on the
conveyor belt and tried to pull out the
camera bag and it was really like an I
Love Lucy episode and she had that
aspect to her personality which was yeah
there was whole kind of Lucy esque side
to her that she wanted to talk about
cinema Verity and how it only shows you
the exciting parts and takes out the
boring parts she kept some of this in to
make it more real to keep you in this
and she knew exactly she was a dancer
first of all and a pretty good one we
actually have found 10 seconds of her
dancing in 1940 in ektachrome it's
gorgeous when I look at it it's I mean
yeah there's some sadomasochism going on
I think in the relationship but they're
all there you know they're all colluding
they're all there because they want to
be there and and they're you know Jason
is experiencing something that he wants
to experience and the filmmakers are
pushing him to experience it you know
you know in a more it feels like they're
pushing them to experience it in a more
authentic way